get ready for top-level gameplay baby
here we go control trying it's good it's
fine I got I'll lose this place and I'll
get to you in no time I landed where I
wanted to land I thought the first blood
was gonna be you right off yeah yeah
that was a real good reenactment of me
yeah great job oh is it
dizzy jump master isn't jump master
don't ever
I don't know how jumping works I don't
know how you work we saw I don't
understand who you are and who do you
think you are you're right I'm back hey
what's up how it do what devotion it's
your boy Marky move anyone landed there
hmm I landed there trust me I wouldn't
lie to you don't mind me laughing when I
say that you wouldn't lie you say these
things Bob mark would never lie way you
yes twice for yes don't worry guys I'm
coming why do I have the absolute worst
luck when it comes to looting out quit
moaning let's know it I guess there's a
detachment on this worst scope ever on
it dude dude
this crazy thing if you guys know video
games are supposed to be for funsies
I got Mozambique blowy thing what Chloe
thing looks like a ship I don't know
respawn is that you can respawn in this
game yeah so when your ally dies you can
pick up a banner off of their body and
then take it to a respawn point and they
come back in the game they respond yeah
heavy megwin building Markson yeah it's
gone mysteriously it's super weird there
it is he was mistaken it was an epic I
already I already have one of those Wade
you were mistaken about a lot of things
pretty much all the time big doors oh
[ __ ] I thought you were an enemy for a
second wait I almost opened fire here
bad guys over here I think you don't
know that they're bad in this world weak
that's true that's true that's true
that's true I feel like we should see
some enemies you know some shooty bangs
I mean we should go to zone I guess we
should follow Wade we got this okay do
we
oh we got this I don't get how you can
ride zip lines up but I'm not
complaining about it it's it's powered
it's like you got all walls I don't know
that makes sense
should we be worried about that
south of the circle I'm running through
it that's over here too you can you can
follow Wade hello guys okay being
separated is definitely I know optimal
drats
a lot of bangs and booms happening
beneath us bad bets bad beds how bad in
that building and to the left of it that
guy that thing standing outside is a
decoy
they're gonna be coming up on us though
which side either coming up on that
doesn't look as good apparently that
that's happening where are they the
right beneath your building oh boy
the hill semi-different team right oh
sorry I thought you were a team side of
us wow I got down come this way coming
this way I've got some various medical
supplies whoa that is an enemy hello ah
[ __ ] haysoms nice moves you're really
sick didn't work
there's multiple well where's the way
that Wade you got it right
Wade oh wait on it wait what oh did you
die
okay we're eliminated q q QQ I was
winning a fight with a guy then someone
wreathed into me
hey I got a revive that's neat that's
nice man what is an apex PAC that's loot
boxes take my money metals legendary
skin yes please it's for Bangalore oh
that's that's your favorite I don't know
if Bangalore is my favorite that's your
favorite in my mouth that's your
favorite don't put anything in my mouth
oh I put it my mouth sorry it's that's
concerning don't put anything in
anyone's mouth nobody put things in
mouths what's the point in having a
mouth we can't put it in just food up
your anus I don't think so yeah I do
are you ready
[Music]
oh nice ice cube thank you that's a sick
skin it's pretty sick right
legendary baby in that's how I roll give
to the best be better than the rest
that's my motto in life are at this time
we're gonna really get it to them cuz
we're gonna live by your motto this
whole time I was holding back you know
oh yeah hold back
missing my shots being all like oh no I
can't
new not this time not anymore give me
that jump master all right never man I
can't control who I give it to it's just
cycle crossing me where we goin baby
this little piggy went to the market
here we go just landing over there
[Music]
pretty good job right I'm pretty good
here I marked the wrong thing okay that
door that doors giving me funny looks it
was the door that I accidentally marked
doesn't into me I know that's why I said
it it was a door oh okay
anybody need a yes I do
desperately I do did you just rely on
the game to talk for you what is it
balloon whoa some bang boom ease if you
go up to that and like up on the string
someone just flew in your zip line up Oh
mark just left what no I didn't just
leave it just kicked me out
Oh what kick you out
yeah just kicked me out it says party
leader quit well that's not good
well I thought you rode the balloon and
just took off yeah no do do Gibralter
again cursed like alright that before I
got I actually got some kill towards
relay we're gonna get the [ __ ] okay away
from people all this time
hey that worked out fine now I don't
know why you're being all good all right
let's do this
what does a wingman do it's like a heavy
pistol
thank you listen I've got a story about
what wingman's do and how it pissed off
Tyler one time when I was a great
wingman
what did you do I cannot imagine any
scenario where a great wingman oh I got
kicked out of the match this time what
the [ __ ] what neat arena it was like an
I'm gonna restart my game oh god there
we go that helps it's good whoa Origen
come back I closed it or it crashed okay
I hate when I'm in my surprise orgy and
the floor crashes down beneath me and
then we're we joined the peoples you
know somehow they didn't want to be part
of our orgy but then suddenly they're in
you ever get that prize ins yeah that's
why I'm always I have a hard and fast
rule about nothing going in me just a
thing that is a pretty hard add family
bend the rule I don't want to bend any
rules that's what happens when things go
hard too fast inside you bend it yeah no
good things that bend it why would you
no one would say to end it yeah bend it
not even at the most outrageous orgy
would they say
Oh bend it bend it yeah bend it kind of
bend it a few times here and there you
know do a little snap action and shove
yeah wait a glow stick yep and then you
shake it we far we're for a bob we're
gonna die but you guys dead yet no hang
on come on Oh Bob you are missing out is
getting no
so cool no I don't do me like that
yeah just like that we don't tell me it
be like that just imagine mark is
surrounded by people murdering each
other just dive in and see it's just you
know balls to the wall okay there's no
one here yeah this is definitely just a
random crate oh cool
through the pass following you you
should I know where I'm going I was only
seven squads left I want to die I hear
gunshots I'm going for it here we go
let's can only end well
yes I'm going in there's no all right
well we are backing out of the circle
instead of into it I'm going for where I
heard the gunshot I'm choosing to have
faith in you guys
weird choice I feel like this is not the
way to push but you know Who am I to
know what just follow me
there's gunshots so I'm going oh god
damn it
[Laughter]
Oh see you know buddy where are you oh
boy I see him there all right there
we're throwing this come at me can't hit
[ __ ] I'm coming for you here we go
we've gotta get hit by my own artillery
strike it's okay this is yours that I'm
walking into yeah oh god damn it who's
here dude get some sick mortar strike
dude thank you
I think a more accurate result as though
they'd died right away
Wow yeah all right another downfield
[ __ ] [ __ ] Christ I want to die over
here
marks just didn't Marcus dropped in it
was like nah no I'm just trying to die
we don't want to live I'm definitely not
looting this legendary helmet didn't
want I take it I don't
I'm taking my helmet off I'm really
sorry Bob we're trying
I didn't think you've a lead over those
guys and they just sacrificed their
lives for you I only got one kill the
other he was already dead so hey you
killed the kill later don't take that
away from you true I did everything yeah
yeah the he was doubt he had a legendary
down shield and some stuff and Mark was
just like I'll kill kill you I just used
all over a man thank you I found here we
go baby it's going down I'm going in I
believe they're down I got one down
what's
mark really is the one of us that's good
at video games I'm down okay okay I
think this is it
oh yeah mark when you go down if you
hold left click you pull up you pull up
your little knockdown shield thing oh so
that's how then yeah that's fine
hopefully that silliness he did lots of
stuff I don't know you did more damage
than me I think I really do just like
coming up when everyone is already low
and they're like what the [ __ ]
this time no disconnects Wade yeah Wade
I'm ready to disconnect right now
there's one thing you're doing right now
I am always the jumpmaster because
you're the highest level I think it's
what it's going but how waves higher
than me man I am the game knows I
relinquish every time relinquish me dead
no no yes yes yes yes
[Applause]
oh dear third cousin okay I like that
was brother work just fine hurt me
brother right here so I'm not doing it
why release yeah everything's slow
motion oh my god yeah yeah
I feel you brother I just sped up for Oh
God I'm speeding up and slowing down
repeatedly buh yeah
I've been experiencing that a lot thanks
for pinging the level 2 Armour for sure
it's fine it's fine
I'm speeding up no I'm not I'm kind of
speeding up that's weird
oh good how are you mr. blue armor
catching if you hit a on the rope you'll
start like climbing ziplining up if you
when you reach the top you'll shoot off
with like your jetpack deployed like
when we launched from the thing okay and
you could sort of like redeploy
where did you guys go yeah you me I went
the opposite direction I got up in the
balloon and then I didn't go to where
you guys were just cuz I didn't want to
leave you guys I thought you were where
I was the [ __ ] out of you
are you sure did huh yeah how about that
well if I die I'm dead
will you did this you did this no Eugene
yes the person that was there Jr did
this little never mind
nice oh he was above me I thought I was
getting sniped from that direction okay
well yeah that was that's terrible
[Music]